(cheerful accordion music)
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] In the middle
of the French Pyrenees,
there's a cake that's been spinning
and spinning and spinning
for over two centuries.
Joseph here has formed a society
to keep the recipe going.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] And he's in charge of a cake
with quite a curious past.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] The cake is
a reminder that losing
isn't always bad.
As Napoleon's soldiers
retreated from Russia,
they picked up the recipe
from several Eastern European countries,
and brought it all the
way to the Pyrenees,
where many people, including
Joseph and his brotherhood,
have kept the baking going.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] So, what's in it?
- [Narrator] Doesn't that hurt your arm?
(speaking foreign language)
(whimsical music)
(resonant tone)